okay so here is an unpopular opinion
Tick Tock is not the problem we are the
problem if you are dissatisfied with any
area of your life tick knock is not to
blame if you ban Tick Tock and then
guess what Instagram would be to blame
you ban Instagram YouTube be to blame
you ban all social media then guess what
we would blame Billboards and magazines
and TV and ads for causing the
dissatisfaction in our life if you are
dissatisfied you can fix it this is an
inside game we are dissatisfied and we
allow the wrong people on social media
to influence us in a negative way
because we lack self-confidence
self-respect self-commitment and the
ability to follow through
you can change it you can change it tick
tock and other social media gives you a
tool where now you have access to
mentors to people who can inspire you
can push you forward can lead you to
believe in yourself more than at any
other point in human history